I've never gotten I got a beauty tip
from another dude which is weird
put some stuff on your face a GQ my name
is Winston Duke and these are my
essentials first stop my MCM the folds
like this weekender bag it's like huge
it's like Winston sized and then it just
also just feels by helis ye someone
actually broke into my car a couple
weeks ago and like stole another
backpack from me so I kind of like the
this bag doesn't draws as much attention
because it doesn't scream hey this is
the iconic look of this like bag and
Brandon these types of bags so yeah I
like this one a lot subtle and great
this one is definitely top this is like
the Lucid body book by face simpson a
guide to physical acting and essentially
it just breaks down a lot of
personalities and archetypes for
characters into things that you can just
kind of do quick and dirty like for your
for your acting work it works for me
really well so if you're an aspiring
actor essential too much juice it's just
drinking this stuff and I hope it works
because you know turmeric has all these
properties that are anti-inflammatory
really good for your skin I'm really
good for your digestion really good for
energy all these really great things so
I kind of live on this stuff so this one
is like the juice but I also sometimes
do like just a tumeric shot which is
just concentrated tumeric juice
I go through bottles of this stuff
because I use it every single night and
I just like in my hand oh it gets your
moisture and all that stuff back so you
keep that blow up and anything that
makes me look better I'm down that's the
thing I never actually hear a lot of
guys I've never gotten a guy a beauty
tip from another dude which is weird
then get too caught up in rigid boxes on
what defines masculinity we're a person
you should take care of yourself you
should feel good and these things help
you feel good you know so take care of
yourself so I wish more men did it and
I'm doing it so put some stuff on your
face this is a big one for me this one's
a humidifier but it's small enough to
pack and travel with it's also an aroma
diffuser so you put the water in boom
take like an essential oil lavender or
something like that you put it in there
I just put it on overnight so while I'm
sleeping it keeps the moisture in the
air especially as a performer your
instrument so your your bread and butter
so this one's a big one I haven't gone
clean-shaven in this past year and a
half even and as a result things like
this have become a staple and you know
my repertoire getting something to just
make that softer helps a lot and I don't
always wear a beard like I said I'm
always wear a beard I've just kind of
been like in marvel land and a lot of
other characters I use these a good
amount and they feel good they feel good
people have been asking online you know
in my Instagram when I do go through
some of those comments and I oh cool
what's your facial regimen or what do
you use what do you do it's a Clarisonic
scrubber
and it uses sound waves to break up the
top layer of skin and exfoliate your
face but it does it really gently so you
don't have to rub on the skin and bruise
it or anything it's just like really
great and then it helps produce college
and once all that first layers gone so
that's really good so I'm wearing shea
butter right now and it just absorbs in
and it doesn't leave any kind of like a
layer on top of the skin so moisture
actually gets in and new moisture from
the air can also get inside 100% shea
butter it's natural and natural is good
this right here is my speaker I just I
carry this thing and it's kind of
getting worn because I use it so much
and a little dirty but I love it and it
kind of has that like little vibe to it
so you chew these things on a table
already nothing else there looks good I
like it
so these are my glasses not a lot of
people know that I wear glasses for I
wear glasses and my eyesight isn't the
greatest thing in the world
Oliver people really cool Brandon I like
so it's always like elevated clean looks
I love gold I love gold gold but I'm
also really rough my glasses I sit on
them I'll fall asleep in my glasses
maybe plastic glasses another big
essential for me is my moleskin
I just like write a bunch of stuff in
here like my notes you know journal do
rule I gotta have it every single day I
gotta carry it everywhere I go
I'm not always the most organized so I
generally have like all these notes in
here on random pages like call that
so-and-so or do this so yeah big
essential you know when you have clothes
that just have a really special place in
your heart this hoodie is one of those
things I love bright colors I'm from the
Caribbean and I just found it one day I
was just like strolling down the street
and I walked into a store and it was on
sale and I picked it up I probably get
more use out of this than anything else
I mean like super super expensive thing
where you tell that I love that you
could tell but I wear it all the time
because it's getting these random worn
holes right there I think there's
another one here it's another one hole
here like it's just getting all these
character bruises you know what I mean
like it's a bruiser I love it